- Hey, Teresa, would you
like to grab a bite to eat?
- Yeah, can my boyfriend, Roger, come?
- Hi, Tony, I think I love you.
- I love you too, as a friend.
- Has this ever happened to you?
Hi, we're Jackson, Jackson, and Jackson,
and together we make Jackson,
Jackson, and Jackson.
And we're here to help you get
out of the friend zone today.
- Finally.
- It's a miracle.
- With just six easy payments of $12.99...
- We can help you get
out of the friend zone...
- With 10 simple steps.
- Wow, what a reasonable price.
- And seems super simple.
- It is.
- We'll give you simple steps,
like step one, climb a ladder
to symbolically climb
out of the friend zone.
Don't believe us that it works,
just ask this guy.
- After I climbed out of the friend zone,
I was finally ready to be
the man that Pamela wanted.
- That's not enough for you,
then try step four,
buy your future lover flowers every day
until they cave in and love you back.
- I bought Marie flowers for 72 days
until she finally came around.
- Or maybe try step six,
call your future lover's parents
and convince them you are the one.
- After I called Mr. and Mrs. Peterson,
they helped me land my dream boat.
- So, none of those steps worked for you?
Well, here's the best step of them all,
step seven, never say never.
- Keep pushing on even
if she turns you down.
- Still need proof?
No worries, take it from Cindy.
She tried these steps
and now she's super thrilled.
- Actually no, I didn't
follow those steps.
See, I realized a long time ago
that if somebody doesn't love you,
that's just the way it is.
You're just gonna have to accept it.
I mean, if they don't have
mutual feelings about you,
well, it's OK.
There's nothing wrong with friendship.
- (laughs) What?
Some people are just crazy.
- The friend zone is definitely a thing,
and you should pay us money
to help you get out of it.
- For just seven easy payments of $24.99
we can help you get out
of the friend zone today.
- 'Cause we're Jackson...
- Jackson...
- And Jackson.
("Later Days")
- This plan is full proof.
- I married my best
friend, who's also my wife.
- [Man in Suit] I'm not a scam
artist, I'm the love doctor.
- Our current president
has used this system
to get his way.
- I'm more confident than ever.
- Can't wait to see all the new couples.